alors plafonner le prix du pétrole russe
comme le suggère le g7 est ce que c'est
réaliste comment on pourrait s'y prendre
est ce que ce serait efficace va
consister question à joseph doucet qui
est spécialiste du secteur de l'énergie
bonsoir monsieur doucet
bonsoir madame sud alors expliquez nous
d'abord comment ça fonctionnerait un
mécanisme de plafonnement comme celui là
comme ce que suggère le g7
y est voilà une très bonne question
parce que les détails sont à venir ça va
être compliqué soins complexes ça risque
de ne pas réussir ou d'un difficile à
mettre en oeuvre mais en gros ce que les
beats g7 aimerait voir ce serait un
mécanisme pour par le biais d'aidés des
pétroliers des transporteurs de pétrole
brut dans les navires qui transportent
des marchés porteurs ou marché
consommateur déposé une liste sur l'idée
que les pays importateurs repayer et du
fait même on réduisait les revenus les
recettes pour la russie tout en essayant
de maintenir l'offre de pétrole mondiale
au half men imbéciles le cours dure plus
pour l'ensemble des pays notamment les
pays occidentaux ça sonne ambitieux
monsieur doucet ce que ça s'est déjà vu
est ce que ça s'est déjà fait un
plafonnement des prix par le passé
ça s'est fait jouer et ça s'est fait
avec résumant un bon taux de succès avec
l'irak dans les années 90 un suivi
l'évasion du coup et alors que la grande
majorité des pays au niveau mondial
était dans
un jour si vous voulez on est posé sur
l'irak un stand l'irak avait le droit
d'exporter du pétrole mais emma se
faisait par le biais de paiements
halloween est l'organisation des nations
unies et les recettes à l'est pour
les dépenses
humanitaire pour le peuple irakien dans
le gouvernement irakien et des extraits
aujourd'hui un non seulement d'amour
n'avons nous pas
unanimité au niveau global pour tenter
d'imposer ce sanctionné sur la russie
mais il ya un lien vers le mans russe
qui est beaucoup plus fort que tout
bonnement qu'il inquiète et qui de toute
évidence ne voudra pas jouer le même jeu
donc c'est difficile des pauses et puis
reste à voir s'ils vont être déçus oui
parce que la grande question où le
risque plutôt c'est que la russie se
braque et décide de suspendre ses
exportations vers l'europe plutôt même
vendre son surplus vers la chine l'inde
qu'il accepte toujours est ce que on
viendrait pas des balances et encore
plus l'équilibré mondial et même faire
grimper les prix
ce que vous avez décrit est exactement
la situation actuelle ou un lys ne la
paye est temps d'acheter moins de
pétrole russe mais la russie avec
certains gros consommateurs comme l'inde
et la chine allaient d'abord presse que
le même volume que quelques années mais
un bib au fil des dons dans ce sens de
la mission sortent gagnants aujourd'hui
et 6 connaissez les deux de changer à
cette belle mesure mais comme vous le
dis c'est comme vous l'avez dit ça va
être complexe un vin d'honneur
l'union européenne monsieur doucet s'est
déjà engagé de toute façon à réduire ses
importations de pétrole de 90% depuis la
russie d'ici la fin de l'année est ce
que cette proposition du g7 vient peux
confirmer que les embargos progressif
partiel ça ne fonctionne pas
tout à fait tout à fait ça a été très
difficile et on parle aujourd'hui et
rool est vraiment le nerf de la guerre
pour l'europe occidentale
l'union européenne s'est pas le pétrole
c'est beaucoup moins le pétrole et le
gaz naturel et déjà on on a un hiver
très dures
en europe en raison non seulement des
efforts des pays importateurs qui
cherchent à la vision de l'importation
mais d'abord citer que la russie vont
continuer à vouloir réduire ses
exportations à se faisant mal mais en un
pour cent des contacts
d'ailleurs le tableau que vous avez vu
tout à l'heure à l'écran nous montrer
que oui les volumes d'exportation de la
russie sont en recul depuis février
quand même manière significative mais
qu'en contrepartie puisque les prix sont
élevés les revenus qui sont engrangés
par la russie eux sont en progression
donc comme vous l'évoquez la russie ne
crée pas de se faire mal on se disant
bel équilibre du marché mondial fera en
sorte qu'il y en aura plus dans les
coffres de toute façon est-ce que vous
pensez que c'est possible à ce chapitre
là de contrecarrer les plans et le
financement de la russie
encore une fois ça semble difficile
comme comme comme les chiffres le
démontrent la russie et sont toutes en
mer aussi en exportant des volumes moins
importants mais avec un 10 tellement
plus élevé que les recettes sont plus
importantes qu'elles ne l'étaient et
compte tenu du fait que à la différence
de la pire des années 90 avec l'irak
aujourd'hui il ya beaucoup de pays au
niveau global notamment des gros
consommateurs de chine et l'inde qui
sont très près à un corner puis la
russie a importé des volumes importants
donc ça va ça va demander s'il pour les
pays occidentaux d'imposer des
contraintes du qui sont proposés tout un
défi donc pour ce plafonnement des prix
souhaité par le g7 monsieur doucet merci
beaucoup pour vos explications
méfiez-vous bonne journée pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez vous sur la
chaîne ici et redit
oh